Another problem that arises when reading state,
is that ,extra unexpected events may introduce
inconsistencies. A common programming idiom, is that,
the first packet goes to the controller
and once the controller figures out what policy to apply for that flow, the
controller then installs rules in the switches,
in the network, corresponding to that flow.
What if more packets should arrive ,at the
switch before the controller has a chance to install
rules for that flow? At this point, multiple
packets may reach the controller, but the application It
is running on top of the controller, may
not need or want to see these additional packets.
So, the solution, is to have the programmer specify
by a high level language a limit of one,
indicating that the application should only see
the first packet of the flow and that
the subsequent packet should be suppressed. The
runtime system then hides the extra events. So
to remind you where we are, we
talked about problems with consistency when reading state
from the network, and we talked about ,three
approaches to, helping guarantee consistency when reading state.
Predicates, rule unfolding and suppression. And let's now talk
about primitives that can help maintain consistency, when writing State.